agents of shield is the longest-running
MCU affiliated TV series still on the
air but as we enter phase 4 of the MCU
shield is going to conclude with a
seventh season here's why the end is
coming no one on a TV shows production
team likes to discover that their work
is ending but it's a rare blessing when
they get to plan ahead of time and tie
off loose ends in a satisfying way such
is the case for agents of shield
production staff voluntarily decided to
cut it off at season seven after ABC
preemptively renewed the series before
season six had even finished airing when
deadline as Marvel TV had Jeph Loeb
White was coming to a close you applied
the simplest answer is that so we can
end on our terms really he also
described as pre-planned funeral as a
quote celebration although that
description might ring a little hollow
to some maybe it's really just an
expression of stiff-upper-lip bravery in
the face of a new era and the MCU great
time for a boba break I don't know man
Marvel TV used to be a separate but
commercially joined division within
marvel entertainments a company that
previously owned all the comic
intellectual property from which the MCU
makes its billions
however Marvel Entertainment saquisili
and a subsequent restructuring in 2015
appear to have left Marvel TV in the
dust after all it's still under the
jurisdiction of Marvel Entertainment
psychrometer
not Marvel Studios Kevin Feige Marvel
Entertainment and Marvel Studios that
are passing of the ways so well
Perlmutter and Marvel Entertainment got
the TV shows Feige and Marvel Studios
got complete creative control over the
films and that's changed just about
everything the Marvel Cinematic Universe
is now its own thing unto itself and
with Marvel Studios separation from
Marvel Entertainment it appears more and
more that the TV division that have once
been so ambitious is slowly being left
behind and ultimately replaced
Marvel TV just have a whole slate of its
own programming set to expand on Hulu
over the next year so the division
itself is not about to die completely
but agents of shield feels more like a
throwback to the way things used to be
and emblematic of Marvel TV as a whole
tether to but ignored by its Big Brother
Marvel Studios while shows like agents
of shield were produced by Marvel
television separately from Marvel
Studios it looks like Marvel Studios has
now decided to get into the TV game as
well Kevin Feige recently announced that
in phase four of the MCU
there will be a whole new slate of TV
shows
on Disney Plus and this move is putting
Marvel television in quite a bind
after all the Marvel studio shows on
Disney Plus are going to be more like
smaller scale films complete with that
bottomless Disney budget and major stars
like Paul Bettany and Elizabeth Olsen
plus they're based on super successful
movies so it makes sense that Disney
would want to emphasize these prestige
projects over less buzzy series like
shield and really it's no coincidence
that other series such as Luke Cage and
Legion have also been cancelled around
the same time as shield they'll be gone
soon enough agents of shield started off
as strong Nielsen ratings when it
debuted in 2013 but they quickly fell
off ever since then hasn't done
particularly well as traditional live
audiences go as always performs better
and later DVR viewing but that doesn't
necessarily keep a production of floats
those declining viewership numbers can
be partly blamed on lost interest over
time as well as on the questionable move
in the fifth season from Tuesday to
Friday quite possibly the worst guy to
be on when you want to be must-see TV
despite these challenges shield is
nonetheless generally well regarded by
his remaining viewers who do tuned in
didn't like that can I do that
nevertheless the show's loyal fan base
refuses to be deterred by critical and
corporate naysaying it might be smaller
than your average fandom but shield
supporters make themselves known by
consistently tweeting their reactions
and there's no doubt they'll continue
watching old episodes in crafting their
own fanfiction adventures for the team
even after the show ends its run Joss
Whedon is one of the original creators
of agents of shield and he's still
credited as an executive producer a show
began in 2013 in the wake of the huge
success of The Avengers of previous year
and back then
Whedon was more than just a director of
that film he was the creative helmsman
tasked with keeping the MCU together but
began to change in 2015 after his
struggle with making the Avengers age of
Ultron and his subsequent fallout with
Marvel Studios brass and so the Russo
brothers who eventually took over
Whedon's place as go-to Avengers
directors in the end it seems that
agents of shield will be a fatality of
this change and shifting corporate
priority it's the last bastion of an
eroded master plan abandoned by its
author that's not the show's fault
but now that the Whedon era is long over
shield is finally being left behind
despite all these struggles and the
looming end agents of shields creative
staff and fans alike can be satisfied
and proud as a show
so close even if it brings sorrow not
every TV show gets to enjoy seven
seasons after all its greatest
achievement might just be that it made a
real go of weaving together a whole
universe for regular people existing
within the MCU the creators never
received much more information about the
films and audiences did but they still
managed to spend plenty of gold and
storylines check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos but your favorite stuff are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and to the bail so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]